Monsoon is not only one of the most
challenging problems in atmospheric
science it is also a very important
subject to study because of the very
large impacts it has on the economy and
the food grain production agriculture of
the monsoonal regions of the world so
today I'm going to talk about Indian
Summer monsoon GDP and
agriculture in
fact couple of years back the the
opening remarks by our then Finance
Minister pranam mukarji in the budget
speech to the Indian Parliament said I
seek the blessings of Lord Indra to
bestow on us timely and bountiful
monsoons so this is how important the
monsoons to the Finance Minister of
India
and in fact what was pranab MJ's concern
it was about the year-to-year variation
of the monsoon interannual variation of
the
monsoon on the all India scale that is
to say Indian Summer monsoon rainfall
what we used to call ismr and whether it
will be a drought whether it will be an
excess monsoon season or what now this
is a figure which shows how the ismr or
the Indian Summer monsoon rainfall has
varied from the time data are available
1876 to now and as I have mentioned
before the standard deviation the mean
is about
85.4 the standard deviation the mean is
given
here sorry the standard deviation is
about 10% of the mean and because it's
about 10% of the mean we Define a
drought
as a season in which the deficit is
larger than 10% or the ismr anomaly is
negative and magnitude larger than 10%
when the ismr anomaly is positive and
magnitude larger than 10% we call it an
excess Monsoon year okay it can also be
defined by Anomaly normalized by
standard deviation ismr Anomaly by
normalized by standard deviation to be
less than minus one for droughts and
greater than one for excess Monsoon
seasons
now as far as the impact of the monsoon
on uh economy is concerned we often read
about it in the
newspapers although uh we could not find
a single systematic study before the one
I'm going to present today uh to give
quantitative assessment of the impact so
for example the impact of monsoon 2002
was felt of course in
2003 and there is a headline in Hindu
which says drought conditions curtail
economic growth okay that it is now
likely to go grow only at 4.4% as
opposed to last year's growth of 5.5%
because of the drought as you
know 2002 was a major drought this is
2002 a very major drought and it had
impacts similarly another report from a
newspaper saying GDP growth slips to
2.6% in the uh third quarter so this is
the way we reach about the impact but it
is important to have a quantitative
assessment of the impact of the monsoon
for various reasons including assessment
of the value of forecast benefit of
alternative agricultural strategies Etc
however the system is complex with
several factors beside the monsoon
having a significant impact so now I
will uh talk today about an attempt of
such a at such a quantitative assessment
and this this is uh from a paper we
published called Indian Monsoon GDP and
agriculture in economic and political
weekly in
2006 now what are we concerned with we
are concerned the data basic data is on
variation of of course Indian Monsoon
rainfall which are readily available
from the iitm website tr. rest food
grain production data from Ministry of
Agriculture and GDP at Factor cost data
from Central statistical organizations
EP W
Foundation now as I said the index for
the Summer monsoon rainfall is all India
Summer monsoon rainfall Indian Summer
monsoon rainfall ismr so all India
average of the Summer monsoon rainfall
ismr long-term mean is 85.2 4 cm
standard deviation is 10% of the mean
and this is a plot showing the actual
ASMR what you saw earlier were the
anomalies from the mean and what you see
is that there are a lot of fluctuations
these are the major drought years
including 2002 which appears here but
there is no Trend okay basically the
mean rainfall has remained the same
there are epoches in which it is above
normal for a long time below normal for
a long time and so on but by and large
the rainfall has remained the same there
are no long period Trends now ASMR
anomally we Define as the difference
between the actual value of ismr for the
year and the long average so ismr
anomaly can be considered to be
representative of most parts of the
country only when there are droughts or
excess rainfall Seasons because during
normal Monsoon quite a few parts of the
country may have above normal
substantial part may have below normal
so it is only when we have droughts that
a very large part of the country
actually has deficit uh rainfall and
similarly only when we have excess
Monsoon excess ismr then we have l large
parts of the country having above normal
rain so now let us first see we have
already seen how ismr has behaved and by
and large the mean is uh remain constant
and there are wide fluctuations around
the mean now this is how GDP has behaved
and you can see that it has grown since
Independence in a remarkable way very
large growth of GDP that you have uh
that we have registered this is the
Indian economy growth now this is the
food grain production all India food
grain production of the country that has
also increased substantially from the
50s to now the it has the increase has
been more than by a factor of four okay
so from 50 to about 2010 you have
enormous increase in both now what is
the relationship between the two so up
there is ismr anomally and down here is
the same food grain production and what
you see is that large dips
in ismr in fact give rise to substantial
dips in the food grain production that
is what you're seeing here including
this one year 2002 also gave a
substantive dip in the food grain
production so fgp is the total of the
production over different agroclimatic
zones which will depend on Regional
rainfall and it's subseasonal
distribution only when there are large
deficits or excess in ismr most of the
country experiences anomaly of the same
sign that is drought or excess rain and
we expect similar anomalies for food
grain production now how do we go about
quantitatively assessing the impact of
monsoon on food grain production or GDP
gross so while the monsoon and the
factors that depend are dependent on the
monsoon fluctuate from year to year the
other factors leading to the change in
growth of agricultural production GDP
Etc vary on a much longer time scale we
have seen right from 50s to now there
has been a sustained growth of GDP so
this is on a time scale of decades that
it is changing food grain production has
also has this kind of a long-term Trend
okay so we expect deviations from this
long-term Trend to be related to the
impact of the monsoon of that year okay
however it must be noted that other
special events which have time scales of
about an year such as Wars economic
crisis Etc will also contribute to these
deviations so what we are doing uh is
quantitatively assessing if you wish the
impact of the events of a specific year
now a major event of a specific year is
the monsoon but there can be major
events in other years you know such as
Wars and crisis financial crisis and so
on which can also have an impact and we
will come to that
now we expect the growth rate of G GDP
to be proportional to the value of GDP
that is we expect the growth of GDP to
be exponential okay because the more GDP
you have the better growth you get so it
is proportional to GDP now parti who is
in fact to be given credit for
generating this ismr data uh at Indian
Institute of tropical meterology has
shown that an exponential function is
also a good fit for the trend of the
growth of food grain production so
approach is that if we fit exponential
curves for fgp and GDP with the growth
rate assumed to be as simple a function
as possible so we do not want to
complicate our life we can we will
actually fix um we will in fact fit
curves which are as simple as possible
for the growth rate pairs of lines or
quadratic and so on these these curves
represent the scenario in the absence of
monsoon fluctuation now we try and
relate the deviations from these curves
to the impact of the
monsoon so this is the GDP and you can
already see here there are some dips
here that occur and these are in fact
the impact of the monsoon so since we
know that we going to fit an exponential
what we have is here is the log of GDP
and log of GDP versus ear and that means
we can fit straight line This is a line
with a certain
slope and then we find that after 1980s
we have to fit another line with a much
sharper slope that is to say the rate at
which GDP grew exponential rate is in
fact somewhat smaller up to 80 than it
is beyond 80 and this is because of
the impact of the economic reforms since
the 80s now had we continued along the
same path we would have gone along the
green curve and would not have reached
as high as GDP as we have seen so what
are the best fits for GDP Now log gdpi
this is just the
uh the growth rate here and it is about
3.5% per year up to
1950 and Beyond 1950 it has increased to
5.5% per year Okay so this is the actual
GDP what we saw in the earlier figure
was the log GDP and you can see it is
growing exponentially it would have come
only up to here had we uh continued
along the same path but since the 80s
the growth rate has picked up and we
have gone on a much steeper slope here
okay are the empirically determined
Trends consistent with what is known
while the GDP has increased at the rate
of about 3.5% during 51 to 80 since the
80s it has increased more rapidly at the
rate of 5.5% okay now this 3.5% was
known as the Hindu rate of growth of GDP
and only with the start of
liberalization in
1980 we have had a higher growth rate
and this has been documented in
literature so what we have found by
fitting the curves is consistent with
what is known this is from a book end of
poverty by saxs Jeffrey SA
and he has a picture of the GDP of India
and you can see this is British Raj
Colonial Ila we the GDP didn't grow at
all because we were being exploited and
now then there is one rate here and
another rate here so what we have found
is very consistent with what other
people have also found now we look at
the food grain production again we fit
curves but this time what has happened
is while the GDP grew faster
than the earlier one the food grain
production the growth rate has actually
dipped since the '90s so had we
continued we would have been much better
off but actually there has been a dip in
the thing so what are the trends from 51
to 94 it has grown about 2.7% a year and
notice that the growth is right from 51
even from before the Green Revolution of
the' 70s and this is because a large uh
investment was made by the free
government after the end of the colonial
rule in many things which promoted
growth of food grain production such as
irrigation making fertilizers available
and so on and so forth okay now from 94
to 2004 actually the FR rate of growth
of food has dipped very much to less
than 1% this is very very worrying and
you see it here in actual food grain
production that you have this kind of a
flat you know very slow growth rate in
this period as opposed to what you had
earlier so the growth rate of
fgp has uh the fgp has increased
steadily at about
2.7% from the early '90s consistent with
the analysis up to the early '90s so
this is consistent with the analysis of
Kurosaki who also showed this now now
the growth rate has decreased to less
than 1% in the last decade because of
the unsustainable strategies leading to
a decrease in growth rates of irrigated
land see irrigated land quite a bit of
it has fallen out of cultivation due to
salinity water logging Etc and decrease
of growth rate of yield because of the
steady decrease of fertility that is
nutrient availability of the land due to
intensive agriculture in the previous
three decades change in cropping
patterns leading to decrease in area
under cultivation so because of all this
the growth rate has decreased and it is
a reflection of what has happened the
world over even if you look at the world
food production then you find that there
is a fatigue of the Green Revolution
this is the very fast growth rate that
was achieved during the Green Revolution
now there is a fatigue and we are also
experiencing it so what are we saying
now there are long-term trends which are
exponential IAL and there are also local
growth rates this is what most
economists report on this is what we
hear on
the radio or TV and this is what we see
in the newspapers the GDP rate coming
down from 5.5 to 4.4 that was in the
newspaper cutting that I showed earlier
refer to this growth which is called
local growth so this local growth rate
is simply how much the GDP changed from
last year to this one normalized by last
year's G GDP multiplied by 100 and
similarly we can have a local change of
fgp also so when it is negative it means
that GDP has decreased when it is
positive it means GDP has increased from
last year to this year so this local
rate looks like
this and this is fgp and this is GDP
basically it fluctuates a great deal
okay now this is the GDP that we had
seen in and this is the fitted curve and
now what we looking at his deviation
from the fitted curve you can see it is
higher than the fitted curve here and
lower than the fitted curve here and
here and so
on now this is the fgp and here the
deviations are more
spectacular okay so now how do we assess
the impact on the monsoon for each year
the difference between the GDP and the
fitted curve representing the long-term
trend of GDP is defined as the deviation
in the GDP so what do we say GDP
deviation is the GDP of that
year let's go back here for example we
take this point here so it's the GDP of
this year minus the fitted curve which
is the red one so the GDP deviation is
positive for this and it is actually
negative for the next Point here okay so
that is what how we Define it we say GDP
deviation in an year is the GDP of that
year minus GDP fitted at that year and
similarly fgp deviation is defined as
the value minus the fitted value now
since the fitted GDP varies considerably
over the 50-year period the expected GDP
from the fitted curve that is GDP F year
is used to normalize the deviation each
year and express it as a percentage of
GDP so this is a minor point we have to
normalize it to express it as a
percentage so deviation is expressed as
a percentage use using the fitted curve
and same thing with fgp but for ismr
there are no trends at all so ismr
anomally is simply defined as the ismr
of that year minus average ismr and it
is normalized by the average ismr itself
we don't have to worry about special
fited values in this
case now we expect the observed
deviations of GDP and fgp for a specific
year which we have just defined to be
related Ed to the important events in
that year particularly the monsoon
rainfall that is to say the ismr anomaly
of that year so what are we saying we
expect the extent to which the actual
fgp of that year food grain production
of that year differs from the fitted
curve which is the expected food grain
production given the long period Trend
or how much the GDP of that year differs
from the expected GDP which is obtained
from that curve that we had of whatever
it was 5.5% growth or
whatever so we expect these deviations
to be related to events in that year and
particularly the ismr
anomaly however the deviation of GDP
from the fitted curve we found depends
not only on the events such as the
deficit Monsoon of that year but also on
the deviation of the previous year this
is what made the uh computation a little
more complicated we could not simply
call deviation of GDP as the impact of
the events of that year and to show what
the problem is consider the deviations
of GDP as well as the local growth rate
GDP GR in the period 84 to 96 and that
is what is shown
here now this is the local growth rate
so this just relates to this year minus
previous year kind of thing and what you
find is that after the drought of 87 the
growth rate was positive in 88 the local
growth rate and so on and so forth
notice that there was a huge dip in 91
and we will see later this dip had
nothing to do with the monsoon this had
to do with the financial crisis so this
is the GDP dip due to the financial
crisis which occurred in 91 and notice
that after that in fact the GDP has been
increasing steadily from year to year
okay there is no negative growth but in
spite of that that when we look at the
actual GDP Visa with the expected long
period Trend then we find that this dip
that occurred in 91 could not be made up
till 5 years later so the curve remained
below the fitted curve for several years
because of this particular dip that
occurred in 91 so we cannot simply
blindly now relate this deviation from
the fitted curve to impact of that year
see subsequent to the major dip in 19
1991 probably in association with the
balance of payment crisis although the
growth rate GDP gr this is the local
growth rate now increased to almost
equal the long-term growth rate of 5.5%
in
1992 increase further in
1993 and was substantially higher in
1994 the deviation remains negative for
9293 and
94 thus even in
1994 which was a SE excess which was a
season with excess Monsoon rainfall and
which is considered to be a high point
of growth per anom in the period after
1980 the GDP deviation is negative
clearly Dev GDP reflects sustained
impact of the LGE DP in 91 and cannot be
considered to be the effect only of that
year so what do we do we actually assume
that in the absence of variation of the
monsoon GDP would increase at the rate
as per the fitted curves hence in a
scenario in which there is no impact of
the fluctuations of the monsoon the GDP
in any year would be related to the GDP
in the previous year simply by the
equation that
uh GDP of that year is equal to GDP year
minus 1 into 1 + m where M will have
different values for this period 51 to
80 and 81 to 2003 okay
so we are saying it is growing with the
uh given rate now impact of the monsoon
and the GDP of a specific year will then
be the difference between GDP and GDP
zero see left to itself GDP would grow
at the rate M now if it did not grow at
the rate M it would be something
different from GDP Z and the difference
between GDP and GDP zero will be the
impact of monsoon or any other event of
that year now it can be shown that the
impact so defined when normalized by GDP
F of that year which is what we had done
is given in terms of the normalized
anomal as impact of GDP will be
deviation of GDP year minus deviation of
GDP year minus one this can be shown
it's a matter of doing the
algebra now impact of the monsoon
rainfall and other events in a specific
year on the fgp does not appear to be
sustained for longer than a year so
unlike GDP we don't have to worry too
much about fgp and the fgp deviations
for successive years are poorly
correlated correlation between them is
only minus
0.05 okay thus we expect the fgp
deviation for any year to be a measure
of the impact of the monsoon rainfall of
that
year okay now here is the final plot
that came out from this and what you see
here is the impact on
GDP and uh on the y axis and the
percentage departure of ismr this is the
monsoon rainfall on the
x-axis um now what you see is this is
the zero line on the x-axis so all these
years there has been deficit Monsoon and
Beyond minus 10 there are all droughts
and they are marked with red dots here
okay
now this this is all positive this means
Monsoon rainfall has been above normal
for the country as a whole and if when
it is more than 10 the ismr normally
more than 10% then you have all these
excess Monsoon Seasons here okay now
what is the impact like first thing that
strikes you is that the if you wanted to
fit a curve of the Impact versus Monsoon
it's a highly nonlinear curve you see as
the deficit increases it dips very f
fast in other words when you have large
severe droughts we get a very very large
impact and you
know it doesn't matter when it is even
2002 which is after so much progress and
as I will show later uh you know the
contribution of Agriculture to GDP has
decreased from around 50% towards the
beginning of this period in 1950 to less
than 20% now and so would have thought
that the economy would become drought
proof but this is this shows a point to
the contrary that even in 2002 when
agriculture did not contribute so much
to the economy still a drought had an
impact of more than 2% which is a huge
impact so all the droughts have impact
between roughly between 2 to 5% and in
this part the more the deficit the more
the impact you know the impact increases
rapidly
with the uh magnitude of the deficit in
Monsoon rainfall but on this side it
hardly increases so we have a very large
impact due to negative uh anomalies of
ismr we have a bad impact in other words
dipping of GDP or
negative GDP uh GDP impact associated
with negative ismr anomalies but the
positive GDP impact associated with
positive anomalies is not at all
commensurate with the negative impact so
this is a highly nonlinear thing and
this was most unexpected so what we see
is that in
fact the negative impact of uh deficit
Monsoon is much larger than the positive
impact of above normal Monsoon with the
same magnitude of the ismr anomaly and
for fgp the story is exactly the same
again highly nonlinear we get a huge
suppression depression in fgp when we
have droughts but we don't have any like
the increase when we have good rainfall
so the same story
again now before I go to the impact of
the monsoon which I'm going to dwell on
of course we have to remember that there
are other events which also have an
impact we talked of the event of
1991 and what has happened
is we can see here
now let us see the impact of
1991 and you see it here see this is 91
so that it was not a very large deficit
Monsoon as you can see most of the
points for this uh kind of a monsoon are
around here but we got a very very large
dip in GDP
because it was
a because of other reasons other than
the monsoon so the adverse impact of the
deficit monsoon in 1991 is much larger
than that expected from the
corresponding ismr anomaly although the
impact on the fgp was near the expected
level so in fact impact from fgp is
exactly near the expected level you see
so what happened is because the monsoon
was not that much in deficit the impact
on food grain production was not very
high okay in magnitude it was
commensurate with what we expect
but but the impact on uh GDP was very
large I mean it was larger than many
many droughts that we have
seen so clearly a part of the value of
minus 5% for the
impact on GDP at 91 must be a result of
the balance of payment crisis similarly
while I fgp that is to say impact on fgp
of droughts of 65 and 66 is comparable
adverse impact of 65 on GDP is much
larger probably because of the war with
Pakistan so let us just see here 65 and
66 the impact see 65 and 66 this is the
impact on food grain production and you
know the anomaly is close to minus 15%
and impact of food grain production is
very very similar for 65 and 66 but if
you see here on GDP 65 is a point which
comes way below the expected Year and
that is probably this extra is because
of the war with Pakistan that we
had okay now in 71 the year of the
Bangladesh for if GP is positive and
near the expected value for the positive
is normally but the IG DP is large than
negative so uh let us see if we can find
this 71 here and uh here it is see 71
actually has an ismr anomaly of 5%
positive and for that year we have uh
impact on fgp is exactly on the Curve
but if you look at 71 you see impact on
GDP is almost minus 4% so big impact
again and this has to do with the
Bangladesh War but by and large you know
there are only few years where you see
that the impact is uh not of the monsoon
but some other events probably some
other events okay so values of igdp
which are very different from those
expected from value of ASMR anomal
associated with incidents such as Wars
or economic crisis not related with the
monsoon but now we don't worry about
that now we look at most of the years
for which actually we can uh understand
the impact understand the deviations in
fgp and GDP in terms of impact of the
monsoon itself now what are the best fit
curves for these that you saw now we are
talking about the best fit curves like
this one this is the dashine which is
the best fit curve
here this one and
uh the equations for those best fit
curves are uh that you have uh 4518
anomal ismr minus this Square you can
see how nonlinear it is it is a
quadratic form you're getting here and
similarly you have a best fit curve for
the impact of GDP as well so from these
best fit curves we can get a first
assessment of how much is the impact of
the monsoon on GDP or fgp and impact on
GDP is16 times the ismr anomaly impact
on fgp is 45 times the ismr anomaly that
is to say a moderate drought 15% deficit
has an impact of 2.4% on GDP and 6.75%
on fgp that is is to say if the impact
were according to those fitted lines
which I just show you and already you
can see that for ismr anomaly of the
same magnitude a negative anomaly will
have much larger impact than a positive
anomaly and we will see that so the
impact of the monsoon and fgp and GDP is
highly nonlinear with the magnitude of
the impact of a negative is anomaly
being larger than that of a positive
ismr anomaly of the same magnitude so
even if the all India Monsoon rainfall
does not vary over long period the
impact of deficit rainfall years will
never be made up by impact of normal or
good Monsoon years now this is a very
worrisome thing because this means that
the integral effect of the impact of the
monsoon will be to decrease the food
grain production over the years simply
because impact of negative anomalies are
never made up by impact of positive
anomali furthermore this
asymmetry in the impact of the monsoon
and fgp increased sharply in the last
three decades whereas in the earlier era
the magnitude of the impacts of a
drought and a surplus of fgp were
comparable in magnitude after 1980 the
impact of surpluses has become almost
negligible now this is the same graph
this is in the era before 1980 where you
have some Surplus
but after 1980 there's hardly any
surplus at all although you have more
Monsoon so if you look at this is the
period from 51 to 80 for selected and 81
to uh 2004 then impact of a 15% deficit
is- 10% in the earlier era and minus
8.65 now so roughly comparable but
positive anomaly of the same magnitude
impact earlier used to be 6% which is
comparable to 10% but now it is almost
just down to one less than 1% so now
you're getting hardly any positive
impact of positive anomaly so in fact
the curve of impact of igp fgp or GDP
versus Monsoon ismr is nonlinear but now
it is becoming more
nonlinear in the later era after 1980s
this is an observation so NE negative
impact of deficit on fgp is much larger
than the positive impact of above
average rainfall the asymmetry and
impact on fgp is particularly high in
the modern era why this problem we have
to address if we want sustainable
development now an asymmetry in response
to rainfall is not surprising in the
light of Li's law of the minimum which
says that the yield of a crop is
determined by the scarcest resource the
so-call limiting resource now during a
drought one expects that water is the
limiting resource but this need not be
the case in the case of normal or
Surplus rainfall however one can draw a
significant conclusion from the
observation that the impact of surplus
rainfall has diminished with time it is
much less after the 80s than it was
before this suggests that while in the
earlier era water was the primary
limiting resource in recent times other
factors determine the Yi Y in years of
normal or Surplus rainfall identifying
these factors can play a crucial role in
increasing these yields so we now try
and see what these factors could be so
look at what has changed over the period
changes in cropping patterns with large
tracks now under monoculture leading to
a high intensity of attack by pests and
diseases loss of fertility of land due
to intensive cultivation because of
these two things application of
fertilizer and pesticide is NOW
essential for getting high yields even
if you have good rainfall you will not
get high yields unless you apply
fertilizers to make up for the loss of
fertility of the soil and unless you
apply pesticides to keep the pest under
control because now pests have become
endemic in many regions so earlier you
know for example in semiarid region
where we worked near pada they used to
be a whole variety of crops grown a
large number of millets and so many
other s and pigeon p and so on this is
the rainfall weekly rainfall in that
region and the entire rainfall profile
used to be utilize now what they do is
use primarily grut and horse G only two
crops are now grown so there is much
less much less Variety in cropping
patterns now so now to understand why is
the impact nonlinear we consider the
variation which season rainfall of the
yields of some important rainfield crops
on Farmers fields and that of the same
varieties under the same soil climatic
conditions at agricultural research
station so we are comparing the yields
in the same agroclimatic region for the
same variety of the crop but grown by
the farmer on the one hand and at the
agricultural resource station on the
other the difference is what is called
the current yield Gap and this
difference between what is achieved in
with the current level of Technology at
the agricultural station and the yields
at the farmers Fields is the yield Gap
and actually scientists at IAT in
Hyderabad have carried out a detailed
analysis and this is one of the figures
from this what you see is this is the
grain yield and this is of several crops
here Millet sorghum and Maze and this is
the seasonal rainfall so seasonal
rainfall increases as you go this way
red dotts correspond to Farmers Fields
blue dots correspond to yields on the
research station what you see is that
when the rainfall is low there is not
too much difference between the two but
as rainfall increases then the yield Gap
widens and what is achieved at
agricultural stations in terms of yield
is much much higher than what the farmer
gets okay so yield Gap is very large
only for above rainfall years and a
similar result Creet people have got for
ground nut soyab Bean pigeon pea
chickpea so many other crops so when the
seasonal rainfall is low the yields at
agricultural stations are comparable to
those on the farmers Fields as the
seasonal rainfall increases the yields
at agricultural stations increase much
more rapidly than those at Farmers field
and so the yield Gap increases with
rainfall now why does this happen so
what is the difference in the
agricultural practices in the two uh
situations the major difference in the
management at agricultural stations and
Farms is in the application of
fertilizers and pesticides in the recent
decades with large tracks of land under
monoculture leading to high intensity of
attack by Pest and diseases and loss of
fertility of land due to intensive
cultivation it is not possible to get
high yields without application of
fertilizers and pesticides however in
the absence of a reliable prediction of
seasonal rainfall the farmers do not
know whether the investment in
fertilizers and pesticides will lead to
enhan yields that is to say it will be
cost effective or not the point is only
if the rainfall is normal or above
normal it pays to invest in fertilizers
or pesticides as you have seen when the
rainfall is low even with fertilizers
and pesticides agricultural research
stations were not able to get much
higher yields and Farmers have to pay
for the fertilizers and pesticides so
they have to calculate what is the
enhancement in yield that they would get
by the additional expenditure on
fertilizers and pesticides and they do
not believe it is cost effective that is
to say benefit is larger than cost if
the rainfall is not high if it is low so
since they don't know whether the
rainfall will be low or not the farmers
do not invest in them although they have
the know how and will apply them at
irrigated patches on the other hand at
agricultural stations Farm economics is
irrelevant because they get all their
money from the government so liberal
doses of fertilizer pesticides can be
applied even then the yields are not
very much better than the farmers yields
in poor rainfall years in normal or good
Monsoon years the yield enhancement due
to this application is very large hence
the yield Gap is in increases with rain
so now what is the what are the farmers
doing farmers in these rainfed tracks
are basically not investing INF
fertilizers and
pesticides
now so they are adopting a strategy
which is the same strategy year after
year okay which is not using any
information that we have on rainfall
variability even if we did not have
prediction for a specific year say 2013
as to how the rain is going to be over a
region we have a lot of data 100 Years
of data and with that we should be able
to see what is the possibility what is
the probability of occurrence of low
rainfall low as defined on that yield
curve so we want to
know see the farmers are really
concerned with the case of rainfall
lower than around here because after
this then application of fertilizer and
pesticides does give substantive
enhancement in yields here so we want to
know what is the probability of rainfall
lower than this and that can be easily
calculated surely that is never 100%
even in small regions it will never
exceed 30% or so
so
uh
sorry I think we
have Okay so so
now hence the farmers do not invest them
on the other hand they do huh so the
farmers are adopting a strategy which is
insensitive to climate variation and is
not appropriate for a majority of the
years for example ASMR deficit is large
meaning uh that you have actually
droughts if you consider the period of
58 to 2010 it is large only for 25% of
the years so on 75% of the year Farmers
could have actually gained so if you
think of a long-term average by applying
pesticides or and fertilizer they can
gain and they can close the yield Gap
successfully but what they're doing is
adopting the strategy which is
appropriate for say 25 30% of the years
every year and that is really what is
causing this huge yield Gap and also
that is what is leading to they're not
getting benefits of good Monsoon because
they're not giving another very
important input to the system
fertilizers and they are not controlling
pest which can have a very large impact
on the thing so our problem that the
negative impact of a deficit Monsoon is
much higher than the positive
impact which will lead on the in the
long run to a successive uh decrease in
the food Grand production if we want to
actually stop that if we want to
mitigate about that then it is essential
that the farmers appro adopt a strategy
which is appropriate to the rainfall
variability of the region now if in
particular a reliable prediction of a
non-occurrence of droughts is possible
then it will have a very huge impact on
agricultural production that is very
clear so if we are to maintain self
sufficiency in food production it is
essential that the loss of deficit Years
be made up in other
years now how do we do that price has to
be at a level at which these practices
of yield enhancement become economically
viable because why are farmers not
investing in it not because they don't
know they invest in it in on irrigated
passages where the yield is assured
they're not investing it on rainfed
patches because their estimate of
enhanced benefit due to enhanced yield
is not larger than the cost they incur
in some of the years now if the price
was hi to a
level to a higher level than the present
then obviously the enhanced benefit due
to enhanced yield will be larger and
that may make it economically viable for
them to actually invest in fertilizers
and pesticides so this is something
thing that we have to think about and
institutional mechanisms need to be set
up to allow carry over the profits of
the good years to compensate for some
loss in poor rainfall years now this is
where it is very difficult for marginal
farmers and Farmers without any Capital
to do but this is where farmers in
places like Australia are able to
actually tailor their strategies to
climate variability and in their case
wheat is not irrigated like in ours and
in Australia three years large profits
can take care of seven years of
relatively low profits or even losses
and this is because the farmers are able
to carry over this so we may need to
make up mechanisms to address
this so a surprising result of this
study which was a straightforward study
of impact of monsoon on fgp and GDP made
by fitting long period Trends and saying
that the deviation of these Trends must
be deviation from these Trends long
period Trends must be caused by events
of the year which include Wars which
include balance of payment crisis but
most often which incl include vagaries
of the monsoon so by saying that the two
should be related we assess the impact
of the monsoon on both food grain
production and on GDP and the most
surprising result from here which was
was not uh expected from the work uh
literature on the subject was the
enormous nonlinearity very strong
nonlinearity or the market asymmetry in
the response to negative versus positive
ismr anomalies so there is a marked
asymmetry in the response to Monsoon
variability with the magnitude of the
negative impact of a drought being more
than that of the positive impact of a a
surplus and in recent times while the
impact of a high deficit in ismr which
is 15% is
9% that of a surplus of the same
magnitude is less than
1% so unless this situation changes it
will not be possible to maintain the
growth rate of food grain production at
an adequate level for ensuring food
security the most striking feature we
observe is the impact of a severe
drought on GDP remains 2 to 5%
throughout despite the substantial
decrease in the contribution of
Agriculture to GDP over the 5D past five
decades now this is important and we
need to understand why that happens that
happens because although agriculture is
contributing less and less to GDP the
purchasing since 60% of the population
depends on agriculture for its living in
one way or another they purchasing power
depends on the agricultural production
so it has a very large impact a deficit
Monsoon which has a large negative
impact on agricultural production has a
large impact on the purchasing power and
hence on the GDP in fact we estimate
that for a drought of moderate intensity
at current levels of economy and
production and this is an estimate made
in 2006 when the paper was published the
impact on GDP at current prices is
around 50 ,000 crores so this is 10
times one of our usual scams so it's an
order of magnitude larger than that and
so the impact on GDP is 50,000 crores or
more and an fgp deficit of around 10
million tons in food grain production
just let us see for comparison that the
Mahatma Gandhi National rural employment
scheme budget at that time was 40,000
crores so this will give you an idea of
of how large the impact of the monsoon
can be and we ought to do more than we
do to be prepared for that given the
magnitude of the impact it's not
surprising that in the wake of the
severe drought of 2002 with ismr deficit
of 21% the central government mobilized
20,000 crores to finance relief programs
including Calamity relief release of
food grains free of cost waver of loans
Etc in addition to such mitigatory
efforts it is essential to identify and
adopt strategies that lead to a
substantial reduction of the impact of
the drought it is also important to
identify and adopt strategies which will
enable us to reap benefits of normal and
good rainfall in the majority of the
years which are not droughts so that at
least a part of the impact of the
droughts can be made
up thank you I think this is where I'm
going to
stop